foreign
[Music]
everybody my name is Josh Welsh I'm
president of film independent welcome to
a very special edition of film
independent presents our year-round
screening program
um before we get started I want to thank
our sponsors and supporters the hfpa and
vision media for making this year-round
program possible
uh thank you very much and today we are
going to have a conversation about last
flight home with filmmaker Andy timoner
and subject of the film one of the
subjects and Andy's sister Rachel
timoner Andy Rachel thank you so much
for being here so I mean I'll just start
by saying it's a such a beautiful film
Andy I've been as you know a big admirer
of your work really from the beginning
of your career and I I don't know I
think this might be my favorite film of
yours I mean the Fawn that just it's so
profoundly moving but also on the level
of craft and what you're doing as a
filmmaker I think it's such a remarkable
film so really thrilled to have a part
of film independent presents
um and to have this chance to talk with
you and Rachel this is one of these
weirdly asymmetrical things where I feel
like I know you very well we've just met
but I you know having spent time with
you in the film I feel this was weird
one-sided intimacy where I feel like I
know you so well but
um I'm excited to talk to you about your
experience being part of this film
um so maybe to to kick it off I want to
ask you a question about that actually
is about sort of what happened
immediately prior to the film so the
the film as those watching this who've
seen the film know it really begins with
your father has made this decision
particular way to end his life and the
family is
lovingly supporting him through this
incredibly challenging period and Andy
you are filming this as it goes and and
that the film obviously goes on from
there
um through his death and but I wanted to
ask getting to that point there
obviously there must have been I'm
assuming big family discussions about
his desire to end his life that way the
decision to do that and also the
decision for you to film it I'm just
curious if there's you can talk at all
about that sort of
how you got to the point of of the
family being on board with his decision
I can't imagine that was easy
um and also the decision that you were
going to film it and and sort of you
know do what you did with it with the
film
what Rich why don't you start out by
talking about the situation with dad
when we were you know how we came to to
embrace his choice sure so our dad you
know was was someone who as Andy likes
to say was like one of the most
tenacious people that any of us knew and
know
um and so when he and and he even though
he had been disabled for so long had
just he never complained he never in any
way talked about wanting to not be alive
um and and until until he really really
really desperately wanted to die and he
was calling all of us on rotation from
the hospital saying you have to help me
die you have to help me die please help
me die please help me die
and I remember saying him like that I
can't help you die I'm I I I'm so sorry
that you want to die but I can't help
you and I know we were all feeling
powerless to help him and and and also
in terms of our decision to support him
there's no question
that if there was a way for him to do
that we were going to support him he had
been uncomplaining his whole life he'd
been there for us his whole life and
here he was 92 terminally ill and no
question none of us all just we were all
for sure going to do whatever we could
to help him and support him
um our brother figured out that Allah
had been passed in California that made
it legal and that you could actually do
this and once we realized that then
there was actually about making a plan
to do that so like following all the
rules and getting the clock to start and
that's kind of where the film starts um
so so but there was no no dispute in the
family and no question in the family
that we were going to do whatever we
could to be there for our dad in the way
that he'd been there for us our whole
lives wow
and Andy how about the did you know from
like at what point did you have the idea
I really need to film this or you know
come to this filmmaker as well as a
member of the family and a daughter
yeah I I um I was panicking about losing
dad and I was also feeling like Rachel
just expressed as like how can we not
support dad
so I was recording his conversations
from the very start of it he was
isolated in this hospital for breathing
issues not to do with covid and they
were solving those but he wasn't going
to walk again and um because he'd been
in bed for five days and he didn't want
to be more of a burden of mom and he
didn't know what life would be like away
from Mom and he didn't want to face that
either
um and I think he just realized this is
it I've got to go and if you love me
you'll help me die and at that point
really didn't know there was a law but
he was also sounding like he was going
to die like he was calling Rachel saying
that all of us the same the Shema which
is Dad wasn't very Jewish really in his
life but he turned towards it at the end
and he was saying the prayer you say
before you're going and
I was just like I have to remember every
word of what he says I have to record
everything and uh so I went to see a
therapist
um because I was like I don't know what
I'm doing like what and this is highly
inappropriate probably to be filming my
dad's final days and I don't want to
hurt my family and doing it and
am I trying to protect myself and I
thought she would say not to do it that
it was a terrible idea but instead she
said if you feel like you should film
you should film so I called Dad and he
said I instinctively know you're on the
right track
um which I had in the film for a while I
actually had that in the film
but I feel like the pesky wire scene
um where he's complaining about the law
of Mike but refuses to take it off kind
of as a more interesting way to show his
consent but it was more than consent
right it was like I instinctively know
you're on the right track which I didn't
know I was on until we were filming and
then it was like I made the cameras as
unobtrusive as possible and the main
camera that had the law of mics was in
the other room so it was out of sight
and that actually proved to be an
advantage for family members to be able
to listen and hear what was going on in
a very private conversation and not ruin
that one-on-one conversation that
someone else was having with Dad and we
could hear it and I found my son crying
listening to my parents and I found my
brother filming by the end when his son
was sitting there with our dad it
stunned I think Rachel doesn't like
cameras very much um and she put up with
it but like I think for the rest of the
family it became more com more of a
comfort
but it wasn't until Rachel asked me to
make a memorial video a couple weeks
after dad died that I opened the footage
and realized oh my God dad's alive in
the Avid and not only that but he's
extraordinary I know that I knew that I
he was my favorite person ever but
what he said to everyone you know
looking at it through the observational
objective eyes of the camera I was
really struck with how profound the
footage was and how important it could
be for people
um because I just feel like we don't
ever I've certainly never been through
anything like this and never nobody's
ever instructed me in any way about how
to handle anything like this and having
Rachel as a rabbi as a guide in the
family it was just also incredible and
then Dad going through his own you know
journey and Arc of of understanding you
know that he that he was judging his
life wrong and his self-worth wrong all
of that plus everyone coming into the
room as a filmmaker I'm looking at it
going oh my gosh you know everybody's
coming in grappling with the biggest
questions of life and death and then Dad
who's dying is comforting all of them
making them laugh with his like sharp
wit which was alive and well to the end
you know and it was like they were
changing so everybody was having a an
experience that was I think really
profound and um and I thought we should
maybe share it and so then then it
became a tough conversation with Rachel
about that
which is totally understandable to me
and thankfully she let it happen
you mean a conversation about turning it
into a taking all that footage and
making a film that would be shared
publicly well I just kept I kept editing
after the okay the five minute it was
supposed to be a five minute Memorial
video in a week it turned into a
32-minute memorial video which I turned
into Rachel the night before her
memorial service
that was the first upsetting thing was
that she wasn't planning a film
screening right
right she want to take over at this
point but all about how that has been so
yeah right so the night before the
memorial so we had to do a zoom it was
cool maybe we had to do a zoo memorial
service and
and so yeah I thought it would be nice
to have like five minutes of pictures so
that like that's what I was looking for
that was a 32-minute film so we changed
the service and and it was amazing
um once I got over what my plans have
been you know and and then and then when
I realized Andy was making a film film
because because I think one thing that's
unusual about our family that people
might not readily know is that Andy
films everything all the time always so
the fact that there were cameras in the
room which was already for me like not
ideal
um it did not occur to any of us that
there was gonna be a movie it was more
just like Andy's documenting this
because she wants to keep it
and then the idea like oh no she's
actually going to make a movie
um
I just felt like
I as a rabbi I feel like death is it's
not something that should be hidden or
secret but it is it's private and I felt
that that this was our family being
vulnerable and real and together and not
on display to the world and I did not
want it to be a film
and I've since fully come around like
completely to now feel like I want
everyone to watch it and I feel like I
was wrong and Andy was right and this
I'm really glad this film exists and um
and so that was a journey for me yeah I
can only imagine I mean it is your whole
family is so incredibly vulnerable and
open and exposed in this in this film
and to me as a viewer it's beautiful and
I feel like it it's like a privilege to
watch that and experience it but I can
imagine as someone living it it could be
very unsettling I mean Audi it
definitely reminds me of like this a
totally different film totally different
subject matter and everything but it
takes me back to we live in public right
one of your early films where again the
camera's always on in this environment
um but
this is so profoundly different this is
you and your family at the this most
intimate moment
um I mean so building on this there's
something that struck me about both of
you in this film like
Rachel there's one moment I forget
exactly what you say but you're um I
think you're packing a suitcase and you
say that you
you were coming wanting to be your
father's daughter at the exact moment he
said I need you to be my Rabbi and so
you're wearing these you're playing
these two roles
and Auntie of course you're the daughter
and the filmmaker and going through this
and um
I don't really know what my question is
but just like because like I've seen the
film I especially with you rich like I
you kind of that's a big part of the
film is seeing you play both of those
roles daughter and Rabbi and it's done
beautifully but
um thank you I can only imagine how sort
of
you're actually wearing Three Hats
because you're the daughter you're the
rabbi and well you didn't know it at the
time but you end up being the subject of
a of a documentary so it's like there's
a lot going on yeah I you know my dad
had asked my dad asked me when I was
first ordained as a rabbi he said
someday you're going to do my funeral
and I said no Dad I'm gonna be your
daughter at your funeral we're gonna
have another Rabbi do your funeral that
was a lot of years ago and um
but I've been worrying about it ever
since actually and then when it when it
but I never really put my foot down
around it because I thought gosh he
asked me if for almost nothing and this
is the thing he's asking me for and if
it would bring him comfort
I'll do it but then here we were and I
and I was afraid that I wouldn't be able
to
just fully be able to be his daughter
um because I'd be like so focused on
trying to kind of hold the space for him
and care for him in that particular kind
of way
but the truth is that all I really
wanted at the end of his life was to be
there for him in the best way I could
and given that I was that it was a wish
of his and comforting for him for me to
be able to be his Rabbi it was actually
a lot of ways a gift for me because I I
left
that experience and his death feeling
like I I'd done my very very best for
him in in the thing he'd asked for and
that felt really important and um so it
didn't detract you know like it didn't
um it was a lot to balance but it also
was very meaningful to be able to give
to him in that way
I mean there are so many scenes that
come to mind as I listen to you talk but
the one that really stands out as the
scene when you sort of ask him to
unburden himself
and he does I mean it's it's an
incredible scene like your presence
there as
Rabbi and daughter and
the way he speaks it's like
yeah it's really a profound moment
um I do that I do that I offer that to
all the people who I care for who are
dying this is this is you know something
that I do and
um sometimes people can can can like
arrive at that moment and like really
speak the things they need to speak and
unburden themselves in the way they need
to and sometimes they can't or they
don't want to
um and
to to our dad
just Rose to that moment in in the most
amazing way and that it it it did like
the ritual did exactly what you would
hope the ritual would do is that he like
he released his shame
by speaking it out loud
and he chose to forgive himself and he
chose to see his life differently and
and he was lighter
yeah that's burdened and you could see
it and that was miraculous
really really amazing yeah you know that
scene also struck me because
like there are points in the movie where
he seems very very old and frail like he
is a dying man he's very weak he can't
lift the glass he's falling asleep all
that but in that moment when he started
speaking he almost seemed younger and
his language was like it was so specific
he was remembering these like he took a
hundred bucks or a thousand bucks he was
a gutter rap like his language he was
remembering stuff from his work life in
detail like this was he had not
forgotten any of this and it was all
present and it was like
it's really amazing here yeah it was
like he was he was revisiting like he
was actually going back in time to those
times and places and speaking from those
from the pain of those places and also
like how how sad that he'd been carrying
that all that time without you know a
place away to release it and someone
actually in one of the
film screens we did ask like why didn't
you do that sooner for him
I mean we didn't know how much he was
holding and also sometimes in my
experience is that sometimes people need
to be at the very end of their lives to
have permission to
let all that stuff go
if I may offer I think it's almost like
being at the end of a flight
I'm not even fine
I I just thought of this but I'm like I
was on the airplane the other day and my
my seat mate and I struck up the most
incredible conversation of like true
sharing but it was as we were Landing
you know
he said well it's safer that way and
it's kind of like yeah you know this is
your chance to Let It Go
um but a lot of people can't do that so
Rachel says I also think that one of the
you know one of the things that was
gonna destroy me for the rest of my life
was that dad left the Earth feeling like
a failure
and so
um that was really our mission and
intent was to reach that moment that
Rachel reached with him and I had no
idea of the video I mean I've been to
Yom Kippur Services I've never even
noticed the name the word the Dewey
um I had no idea what Rachel had planned
but she said I'm gonna do a a deathbed
confessional with Dad
and um prior to that my attempts were
all to like set up all the zoom calls
with everyone who he ever impacted so
that he understood it wasn't just family
it wasn't just us falling all over
ourselves about him it was everyone he
had ever LED in the airline who still to
this day have testimonials for him I
mean we're having his opening in Miami
next week and there's a you know I don't
know the guest list is like 90 people
from Air Florida you know hundreds of
them still counted as the greatest thing
so just him getting filled up by
understanding like oh I I really LED
these people and they appreciate that
you know and all of those calls I think
really he was starting to really feel
better about himself he was you know
there was not any there's no such thing
as pouring too much love on somebody on
their way out of this world and just
adoring him was the greatest gift being
able to just be there and adore him
um yeah I think it gave us all a sense
of closure that we would never have had
without the gift of that law and that
waiting period yeah but it feel like we
were walking a plank you know and it
felt like we were down to the wire When
Rachel sat down with him to have that
conversation
and one more thing I'll add that's
interesting on a film level is that I
found the scene where he says no
filibuster's allowed
um
I didn't I Rachel's clearly looking at
me over the camera when she's like we
did it because it was like our plot to
reach this moment you know this was our
goal and she's like we reached the goal
but I don't even remember the scene
because I was in so much shock and just
focused on making sure the cameras were
on and so but I mean Biden won and so
did I it's just like the most amazing I
know you know and I found it on his
birthday so I was finishing the cut for
Sundance and um I was just going through
and tidying up some things to get it
locked for the mix and I saw something
that just struck me as interesting but
no idea and I matched back and there was
that scene I fell right into the middle
of that scene
yeah so Alan on his birthday so I mean I
I know that this film is about a lot of
the metaphysical questions we have in
life and I definitely question dad's
hand in all of this yeah
you know he was on the right track he
knew he wanted something like this and
um yeah so I hope he's watching
well you know with you you mentioned the
the law that made this possible in
California and one of the things I love
about the film is
there's no obviously you wouldn't have
put this in the movie but there like
there are no Talking Heads discussing
the ethics of this law or the politics
of this law you're not trying to
convince the audience of like the issue
around you know death With Dignity or
assisted suicide or anything like that
it's just a portrait of a family going
through this and you see what that is
actually like and
um you couldn't have a stronger argument
than that like somebody who watches this
and appreciates what your family went
through and what he went through will
have an understanding of the value of
that law that's far deeper than any sort
of you know intellectual political uh
film would have gotten you
um there's another thing I wanted to
bring up and ask you about which another
thing I love about the film is this is a
I mean it's a portrait of your father
but it's also a portrait of this family
the multi-generational family and
especially in the second half like I
found the stuff that the grandchildren
so moving and like unexpected and it's
like you know just completely real like
they all have different personalities
and they they all obviously love him and
it's a close family but you get like
they're teenagers they're in their 20s
they talk the way people of their age
talk and it's so it brings in these
different colors and like insecurities
like the the granddaughter who played
violin who's like
can barely speak when she's talking
about you know
not being able to show her emotions and
things like that it was I just found it
very moving and I'm wondering like as a
filmmaker when did that do
it feels like the film is struck like
you definitely want to show that right
it's not just your father and it's not
just the small nuclear family you wanted
to get this bigger apartment I mean our
family you know Rachel is a rabbi on the
west coast for many years and these five
grandchildren grew up very much together
and uh like Gigi who plays violin um and
my son Shuki are born five weeks apart
um both go to Oberlin actually and we
were just at parents weekend last
weekend
um carved the time out to be there and
then the president of Oberlin added a
screening of last flight home and a lot
of Gigi's friends came she said she was
horrified by the concept of the film
playing there so we put it at 10 A.M and
then half the theater was like sent by
Gigi so they're really they loved their
grandfather so much and they actually
are very proud of this film and of his
legacy being in a film I think but what
I thought was very important as a
filmmaker
um and as someone who's just you know
goal it is to take what I've learned and
share it with others in life
um was that we just don't see people we
don't see young people around a dead bed
like I
I I don't think that we have many
representations of a good death and I
don't think we see young people facing
this and I think it is very I noticed at
Oberlin the reaction from the 20 year
olds was they loved at Telluride we had
a Sarah Klein Kevin Kline's great
remember that rich niece she came twice
in a row she was bawling crying said it
was like her favorite film ever and
brought a whole group of kids to it
there they need some they want something
like this you know what I mean and they
were so moved by it and uh and they
they're missed they're losing their
grandparents and they're not they don't
know how to deal with it and so yeah I
wanted to make sure Josh that that was a
section of the film that I'm so happy to
hear you say you didn't expect it it's
like you kind of see young people here
and there but then you just get to drop
into this section with David introducing
saying you know I said to them get what
you can from him now get the wisdom
before he's gone and everyone and Rachel
you can speak to this because her son
Aton asked the question of the movie in
my opinion which is how should I live
um which that was an incredible moment I
mean when he puts his head down it's
just like
oh
that's the moment
I wonder about that because I mean that
because he's my childhood like that's
the moment even if I haven't you know if
I've watched it a lot of time and I
haven't choked up yet when he when he
puts his head down I I was it yeah yeah
and just that Dad was so ready with I
mean he didn't know what question
anytime was going to ask but that was
what came out it's like who has that
inside of them just to stay on the spot
that's the this is how you live
so he had to say to say respect those
you don't know and love the ones you do
is just so simple and so correct you
know he didn't try to be good he just
was good about the thing about Dad yeah
and even to the point of like his
beautiful humility where he's when he
tops his head down and he maybe
misinterprets what's happening there
eton's you know choked up and my dad
says did I disappoint you with my answer
like like that that that somehow that
was insufficient oh my gosh like she's
just such a beautiful person and then he
says you'll always have my love which I
think
I think Eton can carry with him forever
yeah I know that juki carries his
grandfather with him forever and they
all had this gift of being able to be
with him at the end and receive wisdom
directly from this person and that's
something that Rachel you you've spoken
about this number of times but talk
about like how facing death changes Our
Lives because I think that's what these
kids have the gift of now
is it okay Joshua take us there too yeah
please
um yeah I think you know we avoid death
in our society we we are afraid of it of
course of course we're afraid of it but
we avoid it and we deny it and we we
live most days as if it's not real and
not going to happen to us and um those
of us who have a terminal diagnosis or
you know something like that are like
the most honest of anybody because
we though they know the name of what's
going to kill them or maybe they know
the timeline but most of us live as if
it's never going to happen even if we
know it will we we pretend it's not and
what that means is that we're not
actually fully embracing Our Lives
because our lives are short and if we
pretend they're not short we're not
fully embracing them and when we turn
toward death when we have the courage to
look at death and turn toward death and
think about death it makes us
like that much more think about okay so
how do I want to be living what is most
important to me if I if I'm going to
boil it all down like 2 to like because
my time is limited what what is my
priority what matters most and and and
do it now
yeah
yeah and and my dad's answer
though he wasn't articulating it until
he got to the end but he was certainly
living it the whole time it was love
that that's really all there is
it's like there's nothing more important
just do that and that's just and you
will have lived well that was the final
impetus for me to make this a film was
when I realized that this is Rachel's
sermon also ending the film I just
wanted to give people uh
something that they could apply to their
lives now you know
um which because there's so much in the
film that it can be overwhelming I know
um to hold on to that that that love is
the most important thing and to measure
your life by that yeah more than the
other things that we're taught to
measure Our Lives by right right
I was Rachel as you were talking I was
also thinking about the hospice nurse in
the film who talks about her she's like
no it never gets easier
and if it does I have to quit which I
thought you know it's like
yeah that's really right yeah it's
absolutely yeah
I'd love to hear you talk so about as on
the on the filmmaking side
um
like this the material is so uh
profoundly moving and emotional and and
raw and I'm curious like in the editing
process how you like the film is
beautifully done it's I mean I love the
editing of it and it's like
but I can imagine when you started it
could have been challenging like how am
I gonna like you don't wanna
go over the top or like how is music
gonna come in like how are you going to
build like we build emotion in
storytelling and I feel like you did it
in a way that was like really in a way
restrained like you just let the
material speak for it you let the events
speak for themselves and the people and
you don't like you know
yeah I never felt manipulated by you as
a filmmaker but can you talk about that
sort of how that process went sure I
mean I you know I really from the from
me from back when I made dig I was like
oh my gosh we don't know what's
happening to us while it's happening but
if we look back we can connect the dots
and take people on this on this journey
uh and they can realize the Serendipity
of and and I think that applies to this
film too you know all my films really
but
um my goal is to just viscerally relay
what it is that I find so moving and so
important right and in this case it was
really about
dad's Journey over that time was it was
very much a journey from being very
desperate and very bitter and very sad
and very isolated as so many families
and people have been through covid and
through and so many elderly people are
now and to just really have the audience
sit with that for a while
um in the beginning he's a voice then
he's just a little box on Zoom you know
a little bit of a hint when he says I
changed them about the rules you get a
sense okay this guy has a little bit
more you know but it's not until a zoom
call with Rachel where he says what he
wants to do to Donald Trump that you
really get a feeling of like okay this
is going to be a little bit later of a
film than I thought like this guy is
really kind of amazing and interesting
and funny and Rachel's reaction you know
that relationship I think right there
kicks off the film and turns it in a
different direction
um up until then I really wanted to keep
you in a place of feeling as you said
that he was what it was the word you
used helpless or you know really weak at
times you know he's sitting there that
first shot when he's home and he's in
the wheelchair and he's just sort of
huddled over I mean that one makes me
cheer up right off the bat
um and I wanted and Morgan Dr my now
wife
um who scored the film
um who's in the film
very much a family affair Josh
if she wasn't across the house recording
the score while I was editing across the
other side I don't think the film would
have existed nearly certainly not as
fast and not as beautifully I mean her
score is so grounding and everything
that she ever did that would be drawing
any attention to the music we took out
because it was just as you said let let
it let the let it unfold you know and
just I said please make the score as
much like a loom like hold the audience
and embrace the audience through this I
wanted to to try to create a a sound bed
of sound that would
um would would work with the light in
the room I don't know if you noticed how
gold in the room was you know and
there's this boot up sitting among the
medical equipment you know on the behind
him and none of that was planned you
know so yeah it was just about
editorially taking people on that
journey and and it feeling like this
Relentless plank that you're walking
like we as a family had time it will not
stop for anyone and dad was his Spirit
changed when he had the agency over his
own body and had that basic human right
to he realized I could do this and my
family is going to back me and this has
really happened when he had that doctor
meeting and then that Zoom call like it
just the whole the whole feeling of
everything changed and so does the film
you know
um and so yeah it was just a matter of
like okay and now I want you to meet I
want you to meet our main characters I
mean I went from daughter to filmmaker
you know in this process and I was like
okay I want something that feels like
you know almost like a Philip Glass
moment where I'm going through I would
ride my bike down there to to their
house Rachel's I have been filming
Rachel for years actually for a film I'm
making about Rachel way before I was
making a documentary about Dad so I I
had footage of Rachel in her temple with
her children from that film so I used
that and then David you know went over
and filmed David to just kind of like
get you to see us all in our worlds and
Mom I had footage of her on the couch
and just quietly without words get to
understand and start to find who you're
going to relate to in the film you know
and of course in the deathbed
confessional when Rachel's doing this
incredible work with Dad that was
extremely painful to hear can call
himself Dominic schmuck and all these
things
and I try to pipe in and comfort him and
Rachel says here's the exercise and I'm
like I turn into little sister which I
am and I have a lot of respect for my
Rabbi sister and I was like you know
okay and I like hunch over
um I left it in because I think a lot of
audience members are actually going to
relate to me in that moment I was trying
to tell Dad you're so great you know you
held on to your stock to not devalue it
for all your employees like you were
good you know and
can't take people's shame away you know
so all these things that I was learning
I wanted to make sure were in there in
as natural a way as possible and it that
it could be a seamless Journey
um you know the roller scene with Mom
you know Cooper saying you don't get to
rehearse this it's like yeah it was just
profound there was just it was an
embarrassment of riches honestly and it
was about it was 500 hours of footage
and it flew through me faster than any
film I've ever made I mean it was just
like within a couple months there was a
rough cut
um because I was grieving I was laughing
and crying with Dad day and night it was
awesome I mean except for the death I
couldn't face the raw footage of the
death and I couldn't cut it at first I
needed someone else to just put some
selects together and then I was like oh
but we have to have Rachel singing and
there's a conversation with dad with the
peacock and that you know we have to I'm
struggling so we could have a
conversation about how we do this
um so think I then I ended up editing
dad's death like 70 times or something
but I sobbed my way through many of the
times and I think the most disquieting
part is when you don't as a daughter
when you're editing and you don't cry
anymore because you're busy being a
filmmaker you know that was like
me wondering what's wrong with me a
little bit
but I I hope you can understand that
yeah no absolutely
um and I really I loved the
the way you use the archival footage the
older family you know the stuff of your
parents when they were younger like it
was used very sparingly and it was
totally effective thank you right yeah
that all was after after that after the
like the film flooded the the present
day flooded through me then I'm like
okay shuki's holding dad's hand and I
swear I have filmed dad teaching shaky
to make a turkey so many times let me
find it you know and then the digging
began to find Mom and Dad on the couch
on Christmas morning and things like
that like just moments that I I didn't
even some of them I didn't even know
existed but I see Dad holding a Super 8
camera actually in one of the
photographs it's a great shot of him and
I we can't find that footage so
um I wonder you know if it'll show up
one day but there wasn't a lot of
archival footage but even seeing Carol
Britton or our housekeepers sort of
became like our mother because the
family was really in a state of Crisis
after the stroke
um that wonderful woman who I call on
Mother's Day still you know seeing
footage of dad attending her son's
graduation I found that you know it was
really great to just throw dimension in
for people just so you could see young
Patty the au pair you know
when she was 18. so one of the things I
really like about that is that um in our
society when we look at old people
we often lack the imagination to see
them as people who've had a whole life
we just see them as old people
and what Andy did with this was like
here you know I know the pictures of my
parents when they were younger but the
rest of the viewers don't and here's
this like really old man and then to
like see like to see how vibrant he was
to see how handsome he was to see him in
full living it's I think it's a really
important lesson for us about how we
approach older people in general and and
remember there's a whole story there
there's a whole background there like
um and one day we will be old and what
and God willing will be old like I hope
we all get old and and and when we are
we want people to look at us as people
who are in the fullness of a of a fully
lived life that included the younger
stages too
and I just think that's a really
beautiful part of the film is that you
get to see this like very old man you
get to see like oh look what he was once
like
that's that's actually I'm so glad you
said that because the whole you know
even the synopsis of the film says
behind this white picket fence you know
just there are so many Treasure troves
of people yes Among Us or they're behind
doors right yes we have to remember that
exactly right remember that q a in Santa
Monica where that man was struggling yes
about you know he's struggling his
walker was over here and he was trying
to get up and Mom was in the in the
middle of the Q a was like someone
helped that man
and I just I just felt like oh my gosh
he was 20 once and yeah go get popcorn
you know yes you have to remember that
yeah when I was watching some of the
footage the footage of your father when
he was younger
yeah I I agree with everything you're
saying about it but also it felt like it
wasn't that long ago like right it's not
like footage from World War II it's like
this is the 1980s life is so short it's
really cool
yes yeah and that is a huge message of
the film it's like this is going to be
us soon and and like and let's live
um
I loved the there was um in my I watched
this film with my wife and she called
this out and I loved it as well with the
the footage of the dogs there's this one
moment in the film where you just show
the animals and we have six animals in
our house so like I've noticed yeah
there's one of them here but um I just
love that that you capture that element
of
like what the house feels like like the
animals are there like all this
momentous stuff is going on and the the
dogs are walking around sniffing you
know it's like yeah oh yeah and they're
and they're all they are all part of the
family I mean my mom's dog ebony is that
big fat one that looks like a footstool
and then Morgan's dog is the Dachshund
and they all have a cameo moment and my
husky comes walking in the door whenever
she feels like it doesn't matter if the
door is closed she just walks right in
the middle of the doctor you know here's
the doctor saying goodbye to Dad and
Trixie's just walking through you know
um and then there's the cats you know
when Mom's really like could this doctor
stop Daddy
the cat and the edit you know I just saw
this footage the cat
just kind of looking like could could
the doctor like that
laughs
and also you got to have cutaways so
thank God yeah yeah no yeah well so I
one last thank you so much for talking
and taking so much time my last question
is I'd love to hear about both of you
talk about your experience seeing the
film with audiences or now that it's
coming out in the world what that
experience is like like again mainly
because you're both in the film you're
you it's and so exposed like what is
that experience been like to watch this
with other people or hear how it's
affecting people
okay should I go first so I you know as
the person who is the least excited at
first about this existing in the world I
the first time I saw with an audience
was at Sundance though Sundance was
virtual there was still like these Andy
was able to people put together these
audiences who watched it and I was I sat
like a little bit outside of the room
and like ready to escape I didn't think
I wanted to watch it I didn't think I
wanted to watch it with an audience
and then seeing everybody crying hearing
everybody crying like their faces were
all wet
and just like the feeling of like
they're crying because they've come to
love my father and they're sad that he's
dying
they're so it's amazing yeah yeah and
then and then to hear the reaction the
impact on them
like that it made them think about their
lives and the people they love who've
died and what what what
you know what suffering at the end of
life is like or what a good death could
be like
um or what how love figures in their
lives or their relationships their
family I just I started to see like this
is powerful and then now just having
watched it with many audiences and see
many audience reactions it's just it's
so affirming to have our most vulnerable
moments be accepted and loved and
embraced by other people and it also to
have them to to know that that are
sharing this which was which felt like a
sacrifice to me
um matters like matters hugely and is
entirely worth it
I'll say that um thanks rage
so it's by the way my job of filming
Rachel has gotten a lot easier Josh true
it's true
thanks Dad I've been very recalcitrant
and resistant on an ongoing basis with
my sister and now I'm like oh this was
really good uh is the law working do you
need the camera over there
not quite to that level but
um but no I would say that um you know
the the story I heard that affected me
the most was uh someone called me who is
a filmmaker actually owns a production
company and saw it at Sundance but then
wanted to see it with an audience so he
came to Telluride and he was sitting in
the audience like crying next to someone
and laughing next to someone a total
stranger and they ended up holding hands
and he called me and said I have to tell
you we held hands through the entire
film
and then I walked outside and I called
my father who I haven't spoken to in 10
years and made plans to reunite with him
you know and I was just like oh my gosh
like I've never created anything that
even approaches having that kind of
impact in another person's life and
we've heard time and again that people
see their own families even though
they're growing to love Dad and growing
to to feel like they're part of our
family which is lovely and Welcome to
our family but also they're seeing their
own families and that is a miracle that
is the miracle of film I mean how can
you
we're sharing the most intimate thing
you could ever share and so detailed
right and it's in the details that we
get to actually have a tether to our own
lives and you would think it would be
the opposite at least I would I would
think if you cast a wide net you'd find
some space in the auditorium for
yourself you know but it's in it's in
this in the intimacy of that room that
people can find in their own way in
their own lives so that's a great gift I
I think that it's Dad's gift to us
honestly
it's the Paradox of particular and
Universal that you would think that the
particular and the universal are
opposite extremes but they're actually
they come together they're actually a
circle and like the more particular the
more Universal
thank you
um do you are you like rentable for
you said it's so much more concisely
perfectly if you're ever in New York you
should go to one of her sermons
she's online
I'm very proud of her
well thank you both so much uh for this
film I'm so glad you made it and um and
thank you for taking time to talk about
it too
um
Andy it's great to see you online but
hopefully sometime soon in person I hope
so I hope so and I hope to meet that
adorable creature behind you
he is my work companion every day yeah
what's his name uh that's Angus that's
Angus hi Angus hi Angus two-year-old
Shepherd retriever mix full of energy
nice all right thanks so much thank you
Rachel very nice to meet you good to
meet you too thank you so much for this
conversation thanks for taking the time
too thank you Andy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]